beneath of smear when I look out to see
I think first and foremost about how
beautiful it is and then I think that we
need to preserve this beauty I golf the
van lift it would apply chief is a
climate expert his research focuses on
the sea and climate change the winner of
the german environmental award works at
the Helmholtz Centre for ocean research
in queue I was born here my parents were
born there and we really more at home
here for there yeah that's how about to
feel ultimately I feel at home here in
northern Germany where I was born raised
and have spent most of my life but I
also feel at home here in Pakistan
because you can't deny your roots so I
still feel very closely people who live
there in lenoir Xia MIT MIT invention
teal team germany Latif is known for
being outspoken about global warming he
views extreme weather phenomena like
droughts and floods is proof that the
climate is beginning to change
dramatically what will happen to the
oceans of climate change continues
unchecked yeah the OT on a the oceans
absorb a large part of the heat from
climate change which naturally causes
changes to the ecosystem and what about
the fish yeah I'd officiate fish are of
course a part of this giant ecosystem
and they'll be affected in one way or
another design for one thing because the
food they eat which has to be there at a
specific time might no longer be around
at that time of year and then fish
already faced many other problems like
shifting pH from the absorption of co2
which not only causes global warming but
also acidification
then there's plastic waste and other
kinds of pollution bbs what about the
upcoming climate conference yeah as a
diva to date the climate change
conferences and world leaders have
failed spectacularly I'm sorry to say
since these negotiations began and Paris
will be the 21st climate change
conference co2 emissions have soared by
sixty percent clearly that's a damning
indictment could always yet I think we
can look to the future with optimism the
Sun doesn't cost anything thought it
costs it neither does wind or geothermal
energy and where else can you find that
free raw materials sooner or later their
day will come that's bits if we all rush
beta do he sets a nice do you really
think economics alone will make people
more reasonable yeah a name yes I think
we live in a world that's economy based
I'm not a dreamer I know things must pay
off economically you wish listen ven-
feeling you know a lot about the
consequences of climate change examine
does that sometimes frighten you one is
ever much must lie no no that's a luxury
I can't allow myself it's like the
doctor-patient relationship if you get
emotionally involved you can't think
straight anymore unless accompanied her
for everything yet the climate expert
feuds a responsibility and he's counting
on public support yeah the official
victi that it's important to make clear
to a broad section of the population
what it's all about because we can't
rely solely on politicians to do that at
least in my experience my nap vowel but
you have to exert pressure from below
and that's best done through the media
thank goodness we have a free press that
delivers our message on details but here
NASA how jaggedy you turned 60 not long
ago why does the fate of coming
generations concern you so much was a
held adored yeah he cut in give us a
visor una bala see I've had a pretty
wonderful life on this planet which
offers everything you could ever want
and I simply wish that coming
generations will be just as lucky as I
apprentices oh I go to school com vieja
suddenly summer giblet if you won't give
up he continued with his research and
his warnings on the consequences of
climate change